the Joe Rogan experience how many people
you think live in Boulder Colorado 100
sounds low Boulder pretty big really the
school is there and the school alone has
got to be 70 K what's 100 7,107 all
right
yeah but that schools got to take up the
high majority of that population isn't
that school massive that schools [ __ ]
huge I mean 5060 thousand kids that's
the most for like any school really like
Ohio State or Texas is like 50 60 yeah
but isn't Boulder but like sounds are
strange right you got young people and
the old people who like staying near the
university do people use to complain
when I was in Arizona State people would
[ __ ] constantly about us or in house
parties like where do you [ __ ] think
this schools been around since 1896 yeah
and they used to be in those parties
these are [ __ ] yes so stop shows either
[ __ ] come over and get high with us
or move let's move you got to move dude
it's not Mike the school's been there
when somebody moves to a school area and
they complain yeah well you know you
know what they did about Westwood UCLA
that whole thing is [ __ ] up well
that's why there's no college town there
because those community organizers
basically made it almost impossible for
young and new businesses to open up that
would be supportive of like bars or
restaurant culture they keep shutting it
down because these old rich people in
Westwood don't want that there they want
it to be a neighborhood they fight UCLA
tooth and nail to make sure that it's
like no make the kids go [ __ ] live in
Culver City or something it's bull it's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] yeah that's why
the house was out there you wouldn't be
thinking suppose I wouldn't move to a
place where a college is I wouldn't move
a block from a [ __ ] major university
how about that when I was in Boulder I
was driving down the street and I saw
four tourney house and I said imagine
you're in a Zac Efron movie and you live
right next to order these [ __ ] like
that that's like a Zac Efron yeah Seth
Rogen movie yeah what does it call
neighbors yeah yeah but do you know
better that's what I mean you know where
you're moving you know where you move if
you don't next to a major school it's
your fault whatever it's really cheap to
live in extra course it is what he needs
but it's gotta come out of house yeah
that like is there anything that [ __ ]
with your real-estate value more than a
fraternity sorority it's like I bet
they're loud but they're probably not
gonna be lighting anything on fire
no because they go to the guy's house
they go to the frat to [ __ ] [ __ ] up well
also
the dudes are the ones that are the
problems in terms of like violence and
explosions and in chaos
yeah drunk men they're way scarier than
drunk women play drunk will just cry
they scream they tell [ __ ] they're
gonna cut them they might pull hair and
punch each other but it's nothing
there's not bombs going on man of
shooting guns and lighting cars on fire
and they're doing dumb things drunk
winner [ __ ] Danes but that's what
you're supposed to do when you're that
age where's you're supposed to do dumb
[ __ ] we just first start getting drunk
and you're also supposed to realize how
dumb it is that you're living in the
house with these [ __ ] savage men
mm-hmm like I gotta grow up and then by
time those three years or four years are
done and you're out you're like enough
I'm gonna be a different person
turnovers I'm gonna live a llama to be a
venture capitalist I'm gonna do I'm
gonna be an angel investor and put two
of those guys no two of those guys still
want to keep that park ricer became
[ __ ] comedian yeah they just can't
get out Burt Burt was at school for a
hundred years yeah I mean how long this
thing called seven seven years he never
graduated I don't know if he did or not
does he have a degree I guarantee you we
bribed somebody you know it's got to be
in hotel management if yeah if he has
one I bet you that's with it
imagine if he did spend all those years
on school tuition what a waste so much
but isn't isn't his parent too he comes
from money right he'd what what what is
top partier he had a degree in
hospitality I swear to God in my life I
did not know that but I just knew it in
my bones I knew it in my phone oh did
that they went for one buddy did
agriculture you know
yeah but Agriculture's real we need food
he had nothing to do with it it was just
a thing to do to cuz he didn't know what
the [ __ ] that's so funny
how much did that cost to get a degree
in hospitality that he'll never use what
do you got to say how many how much a
year is FSU look he's had he's got an
amazing career in stand-up comedy and
I'm sure his experiences in the
university probably did something to
enhance his perspective that would help
him on stage and stand well they made a
[ __ ] movie out of it I mean
and even while their money for that way
no that's the story was but was they
borrowed it
yeah they twisted it but it was all
based on Bert Kreischer total Van Wilder
movie that was his time Bert Kreischer
yes there's an English major for six
years he's like it's too hard I can't
speak no English I speak Florida yeah he
looks he looks exactly like what I
Florida was a person and because Florida
was a human embodiment of a [ __ ] Bert
Kreischer
yeah with like like a weird hat on yeah
yeah yeah well no shirt no shirt no
baseball hat not even a baseball hat you
know like one of them weird fedoras yeah
kind of like a half-ass Fedora yeah no
but no shirt no shirt and flip that's
Florida's flip-flops ever he gave me a
pair of his own flip-flops he's got a
company that makes flip-flops now Bert
does it does what did they call it what
I call
birdies that's insane
Bert Bert investing in a flip-flop
company is a now and it's a company that
pre-existed and then he bought into it
or he started its made oh I did squats
yesterday that hurt
so it says Bert Kreischer free waters
free water that's the name of the
company I guess they're a very solid
flip-flop though thumbs up yeah they're
yeah if you're into flip-flops these are
great
[Applause]